a former Rockstar developer has tried to
explain why the PC version of Grand
Theft Auto 6 will be coming out later
than the console versions this comes
from Mike York who worked as an animator
at Rockstar in England for six years and
he said the reason why a PC Port comes
later and not the first thing that comes
out is because they want to prioritize
what sells most of the time especially
in the past PlayStation was the big
seller PlayStation was a console to have
it's sold more than any other console
for the most part everybody's playing
PlayStation York even said that for GTA
5 they prioritized the PlayStation
version while effectively working on a
ported version for the Xbox 360 and yeah
as we of course know because of all the
terrible PC releases that tend to come
out making games to PC is just a lot
harder